ross was it part of your job as head
writer to select some of the staff
writers and if so what qualities did you
look for in them
most of the time was my job it sort of
depends where
the show was some one time
the show had come from a very productive
sitcom company
called miller boyette and they had
multiple shows and lots of writers
already
and they had written miller hadn't bill
bickley and michael warren had
written a pilot and i was hired to come
run the show because they couldn't run
all these shows
themselves they had already staffed the
show i knew many of the writers but
that time i was the last person hired
other times i took over a show that was
already
in progress another miller boyette show
called step by step
i came in to run the show in the second
year so
much of the staff was in place and in
fact half of it had been writers that i
had worked with on the other miller
boyat show so i knew them
and thought highly of them but there
were a couple of slots i needed to fill
in other cases uh especially when it was
a new show where i had written the pilot
and the show
was going into its first season uh it's
a blank slate and i had to put together
a writing staff from scratch there
people i knew sometimes people i had not
worked with before
i always tried to make sure we had
somewhat of a balance
gender wise especially on family sitcoms
where we were going to be writing about
male points of view and female points of
view and i did not think it was a good
idea to just have men
writing what teenage girls think uh and
so on
um so i've done sort of all those
variations of hiring the staff
and well yes what qualities you look for
i want to make sure that
i think they're good writers so what
does that mean that they that they put
character writing ahead of the joke per
se that they don't just
pitch wild jokes but are are that
they're telling a story they're telling
a real story i thought that was
incredibly important on family sitcoms
because they're so rooted
in that basic storyline that you're
telling about those almost
tribal experiences that we've all gone
through about getting your first bra
or your driver's license or all those
kind of rites of passage that kids
and families go through um
uh i also want them to especially when i
was working on the what was called tgif
the abc's family friday
hidden family friendly shows there some
writers who had worked on very high
profile shows
did not think very highly of the those
shows the abc kid and family shows
and yet some of them would interview for
a job because they needed a job
and i needed to make sure that they had
a good attitude about being on the show
that drawn because if you
just think i'll be there for the
paycheck but this this shows terrible
i don't think you're a very happy member
of a team then
so i tried to avoid that situation and
and largely did
how would you see that in someone that's
interesting um
well i'll give you a specific example i
had a writer who had actually worked at
miller boyette before and when i was and
he's a
really nice guy but he was saying to me
i don't want to have to take notes from
miller and boyette and i just had to say
to him they own the company i can't tell
you you're not going to take notes from
these guys
you know it's their candy store and so
we're here working for them
this is not a job for you and we parted
friends and he went off and found other
shows to work on there but that would
have been a bad situation he wouldn't
have been happy
and then i wouldn't have been happy
because i would have been having this
person
in his case he was i was looking for a
second in command person
i need that person to uh really be happy
coming to work and not be unhappy